Russian ruble is really something wasn't
it
what is it signal to see such an abrupt
evaluation well I think it's a number of
things obviously as you said earlier on
it's it's it's the collapse in oil
prices that we've seen since the middle
of June but it's also I think somewhat
unexpected severe impact of the
sanctions imposed by the West on on
Russia the impact is having on the
economy I think actually the surprise
the Russian surprise the Russian
government how severe the impact has
been and you're hearing now that there
may be a recession next year
all of this is contributing to the
weaker ruble everyone's lost confidence
and of course there's a lot of capital
flight as well Jeff helped me out with
some Kremlinology I'm curious about the
Russian decision to cancel the South
Stream pipeline that would have you know
gone around the Ukraine and straight
into to Europe this is a concession
something that Vladimir Putin has not
really been keen to make in the last two
or three I suspect is more linked to the
sanctions themselves overall them to the
pipeline per say in other words the
sanctions are really hurting the the
Russian economy much more so than the
government expected and therefore either
what's going on here is they're looking
for some easing of sanctions will be
helpful they're easing of sanctions and
whether it's on the cover the FT this
morning here is a nature Scarlett we
need to do a log chart because it shows
percentage change and this is Steve
hanky johns-hopkins this curve here is
on a log chart this shows that tension
and you wonder how much Russia climb
this is the dollar strength against the
rule we did in the brutality years
Trichet would say the rapidity of this
and then the overview of the sanctions
yeah his of the pipeline you know it's
interesting though this morning we've
been asking for two months when will
Putin crack as we watch the rule will go
up I think we might have seen it with
that line I think you might have done I
think also this the market wants the
central bank to raise interest rates
further to really defend the currency
and and nobody really right nobody
really trusts whether there's gonna be
capital controls or not so I think the
markets are pushing the Russians to
respond it Scarlett here's the FT this
morning with that same Russian chart
inverted abrupt evaluation but it is
Bremen says we're finally there
well perhaps maybe this
there are some capital controls in place
as well more than 10,000 you can't get
out more than $10,000 in Russian banks
right now but this is what bothers
equity investors thinking of going back
into a very very cheap Russian market
he's all they gonna walk into a market
they find they can't get their capital
out that is the world could so now we
don't think there'd be capital controls
but it's obviously a risk and until
people know the risk is gone they're
gonna be very wary of investing in
Russia
well the backdrop here is that Russia
hasn't done enough to diversify its
economy other countries that have
similarly been dependent on oil in the
past have made moves Mexico for instance
what can a country like Russia learn
from Mexico's example well I guess what
you need to see is some sort of building
up of manufacturing industry to a
greater extent
I mean Russia's really had not had a lot
of incentive to diversify the economic
soils been such a big winner for so long
but a greater building manufacturing
industry build up their markets for
manufacturing products increase the
quality they've got a huge what is it
400 million people sitting on their
doorstep in Europe so Mexico is
benefited enormously from the list of
the u.s. so does that mean that Putin
has to make more concessions in order to
move in that direction I don't know by
that I just think he's looking for the
easing of sanctions and that is
something that some well I think that
will probably meant ridiculous I thought
I would might lightly in 2015 I wouldn't
be at all surprised a lot of the
Europeans very uncomfortable with the
degree of sanctions on Russia